j'ai déjà dit chanteuse c'est peut-être
pas mon truc finalement
[Musique]
alors
Chantal Goya est-ce que vous vous êtes
déjà dit le prochain qui me parle du jeu
de la vérité je lui mets une grosse
patate je crois que le prochain je vais
le faire mais comment tu as vécu ce jeu
de la vérité
est-ce que vous êtes déjà
dit
est-ce que vous êtes déjà dit bon j'aime
pas les enfants mais tant pis
est-ce que vous êtes déjà dit il boit
d'accord mais bon il fait de bonnes
chansons quand même il est pas
alcoolique Jean-Jacques il boit parce
qu'il aime le bon vin mais il voit
jamais le matin jamais à midi et si je
dîne avec lui le soir il boit pas
vous êtes déjà dit allez après tout mon
mec est en prison
est au bout de ma rue en plus vous êtes
déjà dit il est quand même bien gaulé le
capitaine flamme
vous êtes déjà dit non 5 dans un seul
lit c'est trop puis ça fait quand même
j'ai déjà dit chanteuse c'est peut-être
pas mon truc finalement
ça n'exploit parce que c'est pas parti
pour être chanteuse
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire de moi où
est-ce qu'on va faire non ce matin ce
matin
et c'était une horreur
allez hop ma grosse au régime oui oui
parce que il y a trois ans j'ai essayé
une robe et la vendeuse elle m'a dit
vous inquiétez pas quand vous aurez fait
votre bébé ça ira la robe vous ira mieux
je dis mais non c'est mon bide alors
vous êtes déjà dit et si je me faisais
refaire les seins
[Musique]
vous êtes déjà dit mais qu'est-ce
que je fous à 3h du matin avec tous ces
connards en train de chanter papa ballon
mais des fois je me dis
du matin j'ai toujours pas
changé ils sont tous comme des fous j'ai
payé
il va falloir que ça va être
catastrophique et ben non j'ai la pêche
j'y vais à 32 ans ça vaut ça vous fait
pas flipper ça pas du tout c'est moi
c'est non ça veut dire que je suis le
repère de leur enfance et ça me fait ça
un beau cadeau mais tu nous as vu tout à
l'heure
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu